welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home's newest
trailer gives us our best look yet at
green goblin norman osborne the great
willem dafoe joining the mcu because you
just can't keep this guy out am i
and despite other returning villains
getting some mcu upgrades when it comes
to goblin no way home went back to
formula except with one quick shot late
in the trailer that appears to show
goblin unmasked now it's hard to make
out his face but many are asking is this
even the same norman osborne green
goblin well upon discovering some new
clues in this trailer i think this
distinction between the apparent two
goblins one mask on one mask off will
actually be crucial to the biggest
twists of this movie and subvert the
assumptions that many of us have about
no way home so the release footage so
far presents at least three sequences
that norman osborne will play a big role
in he attacks the bridge from his glider
fully suited up cackling and tossing
pumpkin grenades he also appears during
the nighttime statue of liberty battle
unmasked with razorbats and we can
assume this is the same night because
there is a full moon and the shot of
peter landing on the statue of liberty
shows that same full moon and then
thirdly although we don't see him it
seems like goblin will play some
important role in the attack on this
building and based on that truck parked
out front this is likely feast the
homeless outreach organization where
ant-may and peter work and we saw peter
desperately running through the feast
cafeteria in his black suit in the first
trailer where he pulled off his mask and
asked the staff where someone is totally
freaked out as if someone was suddenly
hitting him close to home but now in
this trailer in the feast's lobby we see
peter lunging after a green goblin
grenade another shot shows green fire
exploding and burning on fuselage
outside and aunt may can be seen
emotionally running toward the door of
this lobby holding some metallic
cylindrical object with some subtle
green glow perhaps a vial of oz corpse
serum so i think it's safe to assume
that the unmasked shot of goblin on the
glider at night time is definitely
supposed to be willem defoe like i know
his face looks younger bit smoother but
there's clearly some motion blur going
on here they probably use vfx to animate
him on that glider anyway but still the
nose and chin are unmistakably those of
willem dafoe now i'm not saying it's
impossible that this movie brings back
other goblins from the spider-verse like
harry osborne goblin james franco or
harry osborne dean duhan i just don't
think they would reveal them here like
this in this shot and also part of me
believes that those goblin cameos might
take away from willem dafoe's return or
just remind us how in most fans minds
they really paled in comparison to the
goat you know how much i sacrificed so
this movie really doesn't need them
still i find it interesting that goblin
is masked when he attacks the bridge but
then says screw it and goes maskless
with only flight goggles in the battle
of the final act every other new villain
spider-man faces in this film it's
harder for them to hide their faces like
doc hawk and electro have no masks
lizard and sandman are less subtle
monstrous forms that you can tend to see
coming a block away but as we saw in sam
raimi's first spider-man film norman
osborne actually parallels peter parker
in that he tries to go about his life
with a secret double identity one of my
favorite scenes in that movie was the
thanksgiving turkey carving in which
norman first figures out that peter
parker's spider-man from the cut on his
arm but peter still doesn't know that
norman is goblin norman panics and
rushes out actually in that movie even
after his death norman's double life as
goblin remains a secret known only to
peter parker which was his dying wish to
peter don't tell harry
harry osborne didn't learn the truth
until the end of the second film so
secrecy and deceit is key to this
version of green goblin and i think
that's gonna play a huge role in the
second act of this film how norman
becomes involved in feast and why he
totally stops caring about masking
himself in the final act there have been
some rumors for no way home that
speculate that norman osborne may pose
as a homeless resident at the feast
center and that would explain peter's
frantic cafeteria sprint in the first
trailer someone who he had seen every
day is actually the same guy who's
trying to kill him and if you think back
to far from home that movie's opening
act did spend a good amount of time
focusing on the homeless outreach
efforts by peter and aunt may and happy
hogan who brought in a huge check from
stark industries signed by pepper potts
i think all that was gonna set up some
tragic irony of this movie if all those
efforts end up just getting exploited by
norman osborne as a way to get close to
peter and to his loved ones so that shot
of aunt may running through the lobby
with the green object you can see some
red and blue lights flashing on the
walls suggesting police and media have
already arrived on the scene and this
might be some kind of hostage situation
where sandman and electro are fighting
to keep all the police and media busy in
front of the building while something
else is happening inside the shelter
aunt may could be a hostage rushing out
of the building with some kind of deadly
objects like a vial of nerve gas to try
to get it away from all the others and a
special thanks to extra the world's
largest smart wallet brand for
sponsoring this video they designed the
smartest wallets in the world which you
can track with their solar powered
tracker worldwide this is the tracker
it's solar-powered it's discreet it's
light and you get to slip it in your
wallet and then if you ever have trouble
finding your wallet your tracker is here
to help you find it instantly it's voice
activated and solar-powered two hours of
sunshine give it a three-month charge so
all you gotta do is download the
chippelo app on your phone and then you
can ring your wallet from your phone or
your phone from your wallet it works
with google home alexa and siri so
siri where's my wallet
[Music]
i hear it
i found it an extra slim profile wallets
of which this is one they're awesome
they're made of premium leather they
have rfid protection and you can use
this little button to
instantly fan out your cards so no more
overstuffed wallets no more giant lumps
in your back pocket check out extra
wallets with the link below and earn an
additional discount with our code at
shop.exter.com newrockstars that's code
rockstars to maximize your savings at
shop.exter.com
new stars now brace yourselves because
many believe that aunt may might die in
this film and it's a very alarming
possibility especially since she appears
in this feast lobby where peter's now
lunging for the pumpkin grenade as it
explodes however we might be able to
relax because in this shot in another
shot peter's face already looks bruised
and ashy frazzled hair as if this is
after some explosion happened and then
patting his chest when he's also in that
post-explosion look is a woman who is
wearing rings whose hand and hair also
look like they were in the vicinity of
an explosion and in the shot of may
running she wears these same rings so i
think it's safe to say that aunt may
survives some explosion at least and
when peter jumps for the grenade there's
already some rubble on the ground and
outside behind him on the building that
overhang has already collapsed so let's
try to put this all in order there's a
shot of a green explosion looks like
it's a car bomb or some car getting
bombed and this happens first in front
of the building based on the surrounding
debris i'm pretty sure that's going to
be an nypd patrol car because in the
wide shot the other dodc backup has not
yet arrived so nypd car bombed that
explosion collapses the overhang the
rubble fills the lobby the lobby that
aunt may was running through that could
have been the explosion she survives but
then this already damaged building gets
hit again with a second wave of a
pumping grenade that peter now lunges
for so really the question is is this
specific shot of aunt may with her hand
on peter's chest before that second
pumpkin grenade gets tossed in making
her still at risk or is it after meaning
she could have survived it i'm also
pretty worried about happy hogan because
we've only seen one shot of him in both
trailers sitting in a car as dodc swat
laser scopes pass him and approach that
bombed out lobby it makes it look like
he's pretty terrified that mae might be
dead in this moment but who knows he
could also be the target of the car bomb
i will say when i first saw that green
fireball it does look like the shape of
a person in the center of the fire i
don't know i think it'd be pretty insane
for this movie to go that freaking
violent now yes you may remember that
green goblin also bombed aunt may's home
in the first rainy film lead us not into
temptation but deliver us
finish it
remember that it was terrifying but we
should note goblin did not kill ant-man
in that movie i mean who knows he may
not have cared either way if he killed
her but at the end of the day the movie
did not bury aunt may so for goblin to
now bomb a homeless center means that
this guy has turned irredeemably
homicidal and cruel i think far more
than the other villains this guy is in
the movie to test peter parker we
actually hear william defoe's voice
croaking hater
you're struggling
to have
everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
almost like he is rasping these words as
peter has his hands around his throat
which peter could only do if goblin's
helmet was off at which point goblin
wouldn't care because showing his face
to peter is part of his sick game that's
right i'm the guy you handed a plate of
food to and now misery misery misery
sounds like goblin is forcing peter to
choose kill me and become the killer
they say you are or give up trying to
save anyone at all this is why i think
it's gonna be so important to have older
peter parker mentors to help peter make
the right choice support new rockstars
by checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerge.com follow me at eavos
follow new rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis and
breakdowns of everything spider-man
thanks for watching and godspeed
spider-man
oh
[Music]
you